[Music]
oh
christm just
[Music]
I
good
evening I love we're glad you're with us
tonight my name is cat my pronouns are
she and
her thank you all for being with us I
want to extend a special welcome to all
of you who are new or just here for the
first time in a long time I'm so glad
that you've chosen to join us
today do you want to improve your
relationship with your significant other
regardless of your relationship status
join us for a workshop focused on
enhancing communication skills and
navigating personality Dynamics our hope
is that through self-discovery and
practical tools you can learn how to
build a stronger partnership you can
RSVP by scanning the QR code free child
care will be available for anyone who
are
svps our Easter Service this year will
be on Saturday April 19th at 5:00 we
hope that you will join us to celebrate
the Risen Christ with our service and
then join us for a family meal
immediately following in the Family Life
Center all are
welcome for anyone uh single and seeking
a fun welcoming and safe space to
connect make friends and enjoy great
company
this is a monthly social Gathering
starting in May and will be led by Marcy
Clark if you are interested please scan
the QR
code these candles are a sign of the
presence of Christ within us fully
Divine and fully
human now as we exit the kingdom of
noise hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
Grace now we enter Sacred
Space a space of prayer worship and
adoration a space to encounter
Christ revelation of God
heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your
heart may we all come
home thanks so much if you guys would
stand with us we're going to get started
with our worship this
evening and I just want to invite you to
join in with us um however you're
comfortable this is an allplay um it's
not a concert but it's a community it's
all of us coming together our hearts
forward our hearts open um to the spirit
to the creativity of Christ to the
beauty that he has placed in each one of
our Lives as he weaves the threads
together in this tapestry that we call
the table so I just invite you all to
enter in with us today um be part of the
worship experience because it's for each
one of us um it's for us as a church so
let's connect with each other let's
connect with the Christ that we believe
is good and is for us and is on our side
[Music]
darknesses to roll over my
bones when sorrow comes steal the joy I
own when Brokenness and pain is all I
know oh I won't be
Shen oh I won't be
Shak my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love and my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I'm stand in your
love in my fear doesn't stand a chance
when I stand In Your
[Music]
Love shame no longer has a place to
hide and I am not a captive to the life
[Music]
I'm not afraid to leave my P
behind oh I won't be
Shen oh I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love and my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand in your love
and my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I and in your
[Music]
love there's power that can break off
every
chain there's power that can empty out
of
grave there's resurrection power that
can sa there's power in your name
there's power in your name
there's power that can break off every
chain there's power that can empty out
of
GRA there resurrection power that can
save there power in your name there
power in your
name I feel doesn't stand a chance when
I stand In Your Love my fear doesn't
stand chance stand your love my feares
stand CH I stand in your
[Music]
love my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love and my fear doesn't
stand a chance when I stand In Your Love
of my fear do stand the chance when I
stand in your
[Music]
love all right kiddos y'all are
dismissed to go to your classes thank
you so much kids ministry team Maggie
and Risa
Mr Charles Kaiser Chloe y'all are
awesome we love you so
much and as they go off to their classes
we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people if it's your first
time with us tonight this is a tradition
that's been passed down through
Christian history and we're going to
read this prayer through together if you
um look up on the screens the parts in
red we'll all say aloud together and
then we'll take a space in the middle to
lift up whatever you're carrying into
this room tonight whether it's a name or
a situation just speak those out loud
and then we'll close out the prayer
together again at the
end Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you Vicky
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence amen
let's sing We Will
Feast we will feast in the House Of
Z we will sing with our hearts restored
he has done great things we will
say
together we will feast and weep no
more we will not be
burned by the
fire he is the Lord Our
God we are not consumed
by
the
up
protect
[Music]
together we will feast in the house of
Zion we
will with our hearts
Resto he has done great things we will
say to
together we will feast and weep no
[Music]
more the
dawn my soul be not
afraid for the
promis oh how
long oh God
of
J be
Master we will feast in the House Of
Z we will sing with our hearts
restored he has done great things we
will say to
together we will feast and we
[Music]
no no
more every vow we broke
can then
betray you are the
faithful and from
the to the
Grave us
together bring
[Music]
sh we will feast in the house of
we will sing with our hearts
Resto he has great things we will
say
together we will Fe can we know
[Music]
no in Proverbs 3 it says trust in the
Lord with all your
heart lean not on your own understanding
but in all your ways acknowledge Him and
He will direct your
paths sometimes the hardest
trust is when our eyes can't
see when our feet don't know the
way and all we're left with is this
faith that he will continue to carry us
forward that he will complete the work
that he started
that he is the author of the
story and we get to partner with
him but God today we practice
trust you call me out upon the world
the great
Unown where Fe May
fa and there I find you in the
mid in O
deep my Fai will
stand I will
call and I will call
upon your
name and keep my eyes above the
waves when o Arise My Soul will rest in
your
Embrace for I am
your and you are my
[Music]
Your Grace abounds in deepest
water your
s will be my
guide Where Feet May Fail and fear
you've never
failed and you won't start
now and I will call upon your
name and keep my eyes above the
Wes when o rise my soul will rest in
your embrace
for I am
yours and you are
[Music]
my you are my
where is
without
upon you would call
me take me deeper than
feet wonder and my faith will be made
stronger in the presence of my
savior Spirit me where my trust is
Without Borders let me walk upon the
waters where you would call
me take me deeper than my could
ever and my faith would be made stronger
in the presence
[Music]
my me my trust is with borders let me
walk upon the
waters whereever you would
call take me deeper my could
ever my would be made stronger in the
presence of my
[Music]
oh you
my I will call upon your
name and keep my eyes above the
W soul will rest in your
Embrace for I am
yours and you are my
[Music]
you God thank you that we belong to a
God who is
good that we are called out by a God who
believes in
us that you are trustworthy
that you are
faithful that you are about
transformation and Redemption and
restoration and not about
shame so God help us to step beyond our
own
hangups our own condemnation
the lies that we've
believed and to step out in
faith towards a God who can do more than
we could ever ask or
imagine to a God who pulls us up and
sets our feet upon a
rock to a god of
love and
compassion and
Justice continue to guide us God and
help us to continue to trust in you with
all our
hearts to lean not on our own
understanding but to invite you into
every path into every way into every
relationship and every job and every gig
and every school room God would would
you be there with us directing our paths
setting our feet upon a rock calling us
forward and would we follow hard after
you help us to
trust in Jesus name
amen thank you guys for worshiping with
us you can say hello to the people
around you and then be seated
well Grace and peace uh welcome welcome
welcome all of you to the
table all right we good maybe so um well
it's a a joy a joy to be with you and uh
yeah with you in this space today and I
want to welcome you all but as always
that includes those join us online
you're not forgotten and um anyone here
today who is new or this is just your
first time in a while um we're really
really glad that that you're here so um
let's see we are currently in the season
of lint uh and this is a kind of a
40-day time of just spiritual
preparation as we approach Good Friday
uh that's the day of the Cross and then
on to Easter Sunday or in the table case
Saturday since we rent space and that's
kind of the best time to do is actually
on Saturday anyway um so uh I I should
also mention um I meant to do this back
when we started lint that uh for those
who are fasting something during lint um
just so you know Sundays are a break
from the fast uh this kind of goes way
back in Christian history where um
Christians didn't really feel it was
sort of appropriate like with you know
Sunday's connection to the resurrection
and that's sort of a time of you know
joy and celebration uh so they're like
well it's not really time to be fasting
so you kind of fast for six days and
then you have a a break on the seventh
uh if you so desire so um yeah some of
you are like oh thank you Jesus I like
need a little need a little break um so
the title of my message tonight is the
fog of life and our scripture reading um
we actually kind of have have two but
this first one is uh the kind of
lectionary like the prescribed reading
for today and it's Genesis 15 veres 1
through six and it says this after these
things the word of the Lord came to
Abram in a vision fear not Abram I am
your Shield your reward shall be very
great but Abram said oh Lord God what
will you give me for I continue
childless in the air of my house is
Eleazar of
Damascus and Abram said behold you've
given me no Offspring and a member of my
household will be my Heir and behold the
word of the Lord came came to him this
man shall not be your Heir your very own
son shall be your Heir and he brought
him out side and said look look toward
heaven and Number the Stars if you're
able to number them then he said to him
so shall your Offspring
be and he that is Abram believed the
Lord and he counted it to him as
righteousness now to fully kind of
understand this story you need to know
that we are uh kind of jumping in uh
into the middle here of this uh this
narrative that actually began uh three
chapter chapters ago in Genesis 12 and
uh that chapter begins with one of the
more famous stories in in all of
scripture known as the the calling of
Abram uh later to be renamed Abraham uh
so same guy just for anyone wondering
and uh so that Passage is really
important so I'm going to go ahead and
read that one as well now the Lord said
to Abram go go from your country and
your Kindred and your father's house to
the land that I will show you and I will
make of you a great nation and I will
bless you and make your name great so
that you will be a blessing I will bless
those who bless you and him who
dishonors you I will curse and in you
all the families of the Earth shall be
blessed so Abram went as the Lord had
told him and lot that's his nephew you
went with him Abram was this is really
key Abram was 75 years old when he
departed from
heran so there's kind of two things I
want to highlight from this Genesis 12
uh passage so you can more fully
understand the main one we're going to
be unpacking which is Genesis um chapter
15 so first I want you to notice the
journey uh and and notice that the the
invitation that the Lord gives to Abram
is both clear and vague
what I mean is it's clear in the sense
of go right like leave it's vague in
that there is no predetermined location
right so it clearly calling him to to go
but where it's very vag I mean uh I'm
kind of imagining that conversation like
as Abram and Company and his whole crew
you know his householder packing up all
their things and their neighbors like so
wa I mean it's natural right you see
your neighbor packing up you're like oh
you're leaving oh my gosh so you know
where you going that's a natural
question where are you going I'm just
imagining that conversation like I mean
imagine you talk to your neighbor where
are you headed out
to uh you know we're just packing up
we're just packing up and we're heading
out like oh cool cool obviously where
well that's what's interesting you know
uh away from here that's what we know
away from here and isn't that kind of
our life in many ways sometimes like we
don't know where we're going we just you
just there's a season and time where you
just know I'm called away from here uh
away from this season away from this
place away from maybe that Community or
that situation or experi just I don't
know exactly where I'm headed I just
know the spirit is calling me out right
I'm just away from here so that's the
first thing second thing I want to
highlight from Genesis 12 um is this
promise that Abram uh will or from Abram
will come this you know this great
nation and uh notice as I kind of
highlighted there at the very end verse
four of Genesis 12 um names that of
course Abram is 75 years old when this
word comes him his wife uh Sarai later
to be renamed Sarah uh we know from kind
of later chapters and if you like do the
math and stuff she's like 65 at this
point so 75
65 and
uh yeah so this is kind of the this is
like the necessary background to to
start to understand you know Abram's
concerns when we come to Genesis 15 and
he's he's struggling right because um
even though for us if you were to just
read you know Genesis 12 13 14 15 it
takes you like 10 minutes but different
to live it so between Genesis 12 and
Genesis 15 that's 10
years time
passes
so because of this right by the time we
get to chapter 15 Abram is now right if
he was 75 now he's 85 and she was you
know in her 60s now she's in her 70s so
yet from them you know supposed to come
this child and uh it's just it just
starts feeling like I just don't think
this is happening uh again imagine a
conversation with your grandmother or uh
depending on how young you are maybe
great grandmother who's maybe just in
her 80s and she says oh we're still
believ in the Lord you know you're like
like what grandma oh yes we're still the
God told us you know again this just
starts to feel like I just it's unlikely
uh so this is all the background right
this is why the Lord reiterates his
promise to Abram in chapter 15 saying no
no no no no no no no no no like no some
guy named elzer is not going to be your
Heir and then he of course takes him
outside right shows him the night sky
says that's how your descended will be
and then verse six says and Abram
believed the Lord one of the great
verses in all the Bible Abram believed
the Lord and he counted it to him as
righteousness so what does this like
mean you know for us so you know lent in
many ways is this time of preparation
and patience and waiting for Easter and
in that way it very much mirrors kind of
our own life and circumstances
like because just like Abraham we we
kind of plan and we scheme and we try to
predict what like tomorrow is going to
bring but the very difficult truth is
this looking forward for all of us like
my life just remains utterly shrouded in
mystery it's a bit like a walking a path
in like dense fog you've ever done that
or
driving through a
snowstorm I remember when I was like 10
years old I saw this image of where we
were headed up north we were driving to
Indiana and where my uncle and his
family liveed and we're going through
Indiana at night and it's like this
snowstorm Just Hits and I still remember
the image of the snow just driving at
the windshield and even at 10 years old
I knew like uhoh well this isn't good
like it was just sort of dizzying like
you couldn't quite see you know like
what what am I like how far are things I
remember how we just slow to this like
glacial Pace even though we're on the
highway because we're just ining our way
forward like oh my gosh really hope we
make it if I could kind of sum up the
the challenging feelings of having to
live like this as human beings it would
be these two feelings fear and
uncertainty these are difficult feelings
aren't they just fear and uncertainty is
like this is not our Jam like you see it
in Abram you see it in us and I think
this is why one of the absolute Summits
of the Christian Life is found in the
word faith now Faith in kind of modern
Protestant Christian circles has largely
become a I would call it sort of
intellectualized like it's basically
about like believing things you know
like do you have faith and what that
means is do you believe the right thing
do you ascend to the you know maybe the
Creed or something or some certain
beliefs about the Bible do you do you
have faith in Jesus you know and I mean
certain beliefs about Jesus and who Life
Death Resurrection Etc and this right
this is kind of we've sort of reduced it
to um mental Ascent to these things when
really the more Primal kind of meaning
of faith is really uh it's something
much more like this story is getting at
it's about
trust trust
right thus to to um well in essence like
thinking here back to Genesis 15 Abram
is old right Sarai she's old they've
left all they know they're journeying to
a place they've never been the future is
uncertain the fog is thick and yet they
believed God in other words they
trusted they trusted that not one of
God's promises would fall to the ground
they trusted that although they could
not make intellectual sense of it
somehow God would bring them through
they trusted the Lord even when they
were old and wrinkly and felt like life
had passed them
by and of course at times they doubted
like if you've read the whole story all
those chapters in between um you know
they were like far from
perfect and
yet over and over and over again and
they kept returning to the fog shrouded
path and then sure enough at
ages
191 25 years after God's promise they
had their
baby I recently uh
attended the had the privilege really of
attending my father-in-law's retirement
uh
party and uh he's now in his like 60s
you know and so ready to make that shift
to part-time work so it just felt like
the a significant you know change in
seasons for him so we uh got kind of the
family extended family you know some
some folks to together and just to um
celebrate just who he has been and
honestly it was a little bit strange
because it was the kind of things you'd
probably say at someone's funeral um
because the cool well this was like the
coolest part was we had a chance for
folks to like just share what he has
meant to them and just who he's been so
and specifically all of his children um
had a chance to to share just the life
he's kind of um built for himself and
for them and all that so um it was a
little strange because you know again
it's like the kind of things maybe would
say this funeral but um they had this
which is kind of sad in its way right we
should say these things when people can
hear them you know so so it was
beautiful like they started to stand up
and just share and one by one I would
say one of the major themes of his life
was a little bit surprising um a lot of
his life had actually been quite
frustrating he went through this uh time
where uh he just could not keep a job
like it was just job loss after job loss
after like and not for months but like
years he get a job few months goes by
lose it get a job few weeks goes by lose
it get a job year goes by lose it lose
it lose it lose it it was just like so
difficult financially stressful
so so
hard uh and and if you by the way if you
know him like this was through no fault
of son like Stan Burgess that guy he's a
hard worker you know he was like on top
of it it was just it was just one of
those seasons in life you know and yet
every morning he'd rise get his coffee
get the scriptures have his time for
prayer and like he didn't quite know
what was happening through
um all those years and yet God was
forming him even when he eventually got
through the job loss season and got a
job he loved um even or I shouldn't say
loved he really even that was still
difficult he was like driving through
DFW traffic all day every day had to
service hardware stores all over the
Metroplex and it's like some people are
like cool with traffic um Stan's not one
of those people he's not like super
chill and he just like oh my gosh uh and
yet even through all that like he kept
showing up day after day after day after
day and little did he know like Drip by
drip God was forming him shaping him
into this man of like humility and
courage and
compassion in essence his faith was like
being bolstered and starting to impact
others like little did he know that fast
forward you know 30 years he'd be
sitting on a back patio surrounded by
his wife and children and grandchildren
as they shared like what a powerful
impact his life has had on um on them
there's a a wonderful quote from the
Christian philosopher in essay as sauren
kard where he said this he said life can
only be understood
backwards but it must be lived
forwards that's the trick isn't it cu
only be understood backwards right Abram
Sarai Stan you me like we're looking
ahead and we're just thinking what is
going on I don't know the plan and I
don't like not knowing the
plan but looking back we say
oh I think um in essence you might say
that faith is trust and TR trust is
courage and trust is vulnerability trust
is learning to bless your own life in
the uh words of that old Rascal flat
song God Bless the Broken Ro L me
straight to you that's a great line
isn't it I mean it's kind of cheesy um
but he's obviously talking about like
romantic relationship you but if you
kind of kind of zoom out a little bit
that's a great line like in essence when
I think of kind of faith and such like
we all have this decision right either
um of like basically of how we'll judge
our life either blessing the Broken
Road or cursing
it you know just like Stan driving
through traffic every day just like it's
the broken Ro like this is life H how
are we going to react and of course
faith is that decision to bless
to to rise up and call our life blessed
faith is is this decision to even enter
more fully into life I think there's
this common misconception that faith is
sort of about avoiding life you know I
want to believe in the Lord and the good
things so I'm just G to kind of float
away from my life or something like no
no no faith that its best is really
about um immersing us back into life
Faith gives us the courage to face it so
in closing I want to offer you kind of a
few takeaways um for living as you kind
of walk out this fog shrouded path so
number one gratitude is a way of
blessing our
life and thus entering into a spirit of
Faith rather than
fear so the connection I want to draw
here is gratitude and Faith as many of
you know like gratitude is sort of all
the rage right now feels like in the
culture it's like everywhere someone's
like gratitude you keep a gratitude
Journal you better keep it gratitude
Journal you know it's like just sort of
but the truth is it's everywhere for
good reason right pschology it's they're
all finding out like wow they like
really powerful um why because it's
counteracting that the kind of tendency
of our mind we're just negativity bias
kind of people you know I mean the brain
is just geared to it's not geared to
make you happy it's geared to keep you
alive and so what it's trying to do is
like keep you anxious you know what I
mean like I'm on the lookout for the
negative and that's so of course
gratitude right starts to counteract
that but what I want to kind of name is
I wonder if people also realize like how
much gratitude is very much a heart
posture of Faith like in essence it's
saying okay look so much in my life has
been good so much in my life is good
therefore I can trust God I can trust
that so much will be good right and
that's like a whole kind of future
oriented kind of posture uh second
ruminating on the past or the future is
a Sure Fire way to decrease your
faith I I think this is why um what in
the Christian tradition is known as like
contemplation or in kind of other
religious Traditions they'd call it
meditation um is so f is powerful
because it's this form of prayer where
very intentionally you're just trying to
sort of let go of that thinking busy
mind as we talked about a few weeks ago
the monkey mind you know it's always
wanting to jump to Branch to branch and
be all about the past and future and how
miserable it was you know um or will be
and when we engage in contemplation
we're just there present to God and the
mind goes off and we just bring it back
to the presence of God it's interesting
to think uh God is always right here
right now like no you can't find God in
the past you can't like Journey the past
you can't jump ahead like skip into the
future like no no no you are always
right here right now and that's where
God is so you got to in essence kind of
come back to the body you know it's
interesting the mind can go elsewhere
the body is always here right and so
we've got to kind of learn to come back
to ourselves back to the moment back to
the very presence of God I think that
starts to um kind of increase our faith
third when Panic hits keep a breath
prayer on your
lips breath prayers are these short
little prayers you can say like in one
one breath um probably the most famous
in Christian history is what's known as
the Jesus prayer which there's very
versions like Lord Jesus have mercy on
me or just Lord have mercy one I love is
from John 15 um abide in my love when
all hell is breaking loose I'm just
abide in my love abide in just repeat
that or I love one from Psalm 23 um I
will fear no
evil I will fear no evil I will fear no
evil right when the stuff is hitting the
fan just keep that breath of Prayer on
your lips all day if you have to all
week if you have to because what is that
doing it's taking you out of the mind
which is running all over the place and
it's bringing you right back to the body
right back here now where Christ is
always through the spirit present to
each and every one of us so this week as
you uh can just walk out whatever path
God's called you to walk out I pray it's
a a step of
Faith every single moment in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen
so on the night
that Jesus was betrayed he had one final
meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held up a
loaf of bread and then he broke it and
he said take it eat this is my body it's
broken for you then he held up cup of
wine he said take it drink this is my
blood shed for you whenever you eat this
bread whenever you drink this cup
remember me so as we come forward for
communion tonight that's what we're
doing we're
reentering on the Risen
Christ um the way that uh we'll kind of
participate in communion is we'll just
go row by row here starting at the front
and we'll just form a line right here in
the middle so when the first row is done
the second row can get up and then you
know and so on and so forth um we will
just know you can kind of partake
whenever and however you'd like some
folks like to take immediately others
like to come kneel here at the front uh
some of like to return to their seats
and partake in that way but no one will
lead you through the exact moment of
taking communion uh also you should know
the red is wine the white is grape juice
so this is the table not of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you who
have much faith and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who've tried
to follow and you who failed come come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet in here
come to the
table
for e
e
as we wrap up commun communion tonight
we're going to CL with a song called the
breastplate of St Patrick and um I love
the words of this song because they are
so very tangible and concrete and um
like Brett was talking about tonight
sometimes that path in front of us is
very foggy and hard to know what's
coming and other times we know exactly
what's coming and we just don't like it
and it's a road that we would rather not
walk but it is the road that's set in
front of us and um I want to be a person
that that blesses it like like he was
encouraging us I want to be someone who
can bless even the hard times who can
find encouragement on the journey not
just for myself but for each other that
we can continue to hold faith for what's
up ahead for each other so if you guys
want to stand with us as we sing this
last song tonight and just let it be a
prayer of of acceptance and also of
trust and faith that he's with us in the
good times and the hard times
[Music]
Christ my heart for sorrow as I
thead Christ be with
of family takes all that I have Christ
within me when I wor and exhausted shame
that
I'm Christ
[Music]
I Rise up today in a strength that is
not my
own I'm held by the prise of God that
I'm never
alone when I'm to the side and I to give
up Christ
beide me when I'm breaking my back but
it's never
enough Christ
beide when I work hard but else gets the
reward God I see me and I ask for
promotion and they shut the
door
God me
I Rise up to in a strength that is not
my I'm H by the pro of God that I'm
alone when I climb the first STS
a dream Christ of
IAP
Out Wings
chath me
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are new we would love for
you to fill out a card at the table on
your way out or just scan the QR code on
the screens to fill out the online
visitor
card generosity is the key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan QR code or
visit the table tx.org
we can all use a little more relational
support and spiritual connection the way
we do that at the table is through our
meetups if you are not yet part of a
Meetup please scan the QR code to find
out one that works for
you all right let me send you in your
week with this blessing you you can hold
out your hands in a posture to receive
or just open your heart to these
words
you are a child of
God
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are
worthy you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to
extend that same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact
with be blessed have a good week and we
hope to see you back here next
Sunday good
[Music]
night not my
own i h by the of God that I'm never
alone when I climb
theam Christ
[Music]
IAP out inth and I
to Christ
beath me
[Music]